see youtubers is Charlie today's video
is going to be all about Sir Jorah and
azor Ahai so just careful for spoilers
for everything that's happened through
season 6 so far you may have heard about
the idea that sir Jorah is secretly azor
Ahai he is the one who was promised he
will come back reborn is this new hero
to end the next long night I don't think
that's the case I think the real twist
was azor Ahai is going to be something
different but sir Jorah is still very
important to that so because there's so
much craziness happening this weekend
and George our Martin just confirmed
that he's going to be including some new
Targaryen chapters in that book this
false there's a new round of the game of
Thrones giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video it's for one of
the enhanced editions of the books so
the last time we saw Sir Jorah Daenerys
gave him a very important thing to do
you have one thing to do find yourself a
cure then return to me is a very
emotional scene
I'll always love you
for biology
do not walk away from your queen Jorah
the Andal you have not been dismissed
[Music]
and you play to yourself to me you swore
to obey my command to the rest of your
life
well I command you to find the cure
[Music]
wherever it is in this world
I command you to heal yourself and then
returned
when I take the 17 I need you by my side
[Music]
as sad as that moment is you want a big
win for sir Jorah down the road he's not
dead yet it's important for shadowing
for the future so what is he going to do
he's going to seek out a cure it's a
rate that grayscales progressing he
could make it through the last two
seasons he'd be okay he'd be a little
crazy by the end but he'd still be there
that mission the course that is going to
set him on is where we get wrapped up in
the azure 'hi plotline there's this
runner that there's going to be a
revelation of someone who is the Song of
Ice and Fire who will save us from the
long night this mythical leader who was
the prince that was promised most people
believe that is Jon Snow there are a
couple alternative theories but the big
twist is going to be something a little
bit different I think they're going to
try and flip your heads on it because
all the cast members have been saying
what's going to blow your mind you won't
be prepared for it so it's not going to
be some simple answer but even if Jorah
is not azor Ahai himself the reason he's
very important to this theory is is
because as he's seeking a cure there are
only a couple of places in the world
that you can go to get that there are
many centers of learning and knowledge
in the East a Shai the place where
Melisandre comes from the place where
Daenerys is dragon eggs came from is
this really crazy place where a lot of
people study the occult shadow binders
people with abilities like Melisandre
hopefully the show goes there at some
point but I don't think we'll ever
actually get to it during the main
series red priests themselves also have
crazy healing abilities but usually it
comes at great cost in the books
Victorians hand gets poisoned in the act
of healing it almost involves burning it
off outright
so imagine surge or having to burn his
hand off just to cure the greyscale but
the other place Jorah could go to in the
more logical place would be the citadel
if you remember Stannis was talking
about how Shireen got greyscale and he
brought all of the finest maesters as
fast as possible they were able to stop
the disease before progressed any
further I called in every maester on
this side of the world every HeLa every
apothecary
they stopped the disease and saved your
life so right now the citadel is the
greatest center of knowledge that you
could go to there are probably a lot of
other people in the East but for the
most part the show is done with the east
I think we'll still see some scenes in
the East for context but everyone is
converging on Westeros and that would
mean that if Sir Jorah
if this foreshadowing lives up to its
promise we'll meet Daenerys as she
starts to take the seven kingdom but
before that he has to heal himself
meaning that he would likely go to the
Citadel in who else is at the Citadel
but Samwell because there are only seven
episodes instead of ten you have to
imagine that there's going to be this
increased economy of narrative where
they try to cram in as much exposition
plot development character development
into its smallest space as possible
which means fewer characters in
accomplishing a number of goals in the
same moment with the same ideas Samwell
went to the Citadel to become a maester
and to learn things that would help them
in their fight against the White Walkers
meaning learning how to reforge Valyrian
steel maybe learning some things about
Jon Snow's parentage that would help
them when it comes time to face Daenerys
and her army thinking about the
convergence of characters now if Sir
Jorah were to come to the Citadel
looking for a cure for greyscale he
would eventually run into Samwell and
it's very convenient for them to align
those characters whereby Samwell helps
Sir Jorah find a way to cure his
greyscale and then they both go their
respective ways until they meet again
when Daenerys finally meets with the
forces of the north so you'll have
someone on each side who has some
information that's very important to the
plot this is who Jon Snow really is this
is how we fight White Walkers we need a
lot of the resources that you have
we need your manpower we need an
alliance and look what else we learn
there's this common thread binding you
by blood so there are just so many
reasons why we should team up so you
have sir Jorah telling this to Daenerys
and her forces you have Samwell telling
this to Jon Snow and his forces so they
each sort of learned information at the
same pace we also have to address the
importance of brand when it comes to
conveying information he sort of the W
TF guy who shows up and says there's
this crazy [ __ ] that's going down and
guess what
your father was secretly a Targaryen so
you could tell that to Jon Snow and he
might believe that he might not believe
it but the rest of the people the rest
of the Lords of the north the other
forces that they're going to have to be
working with will need some proof and
that's where you get to Sir Jorah and
Sam well because bran is mr. prophecy
but prophecy is one thing most people
say prophecy be damned so you have to
have some concrete evidence to present
people with and where would you find
stuff like that in the Citadel so
Daenerys could learn that Jon Snow is
her blood the Dragons could even have an
affinity for him but unless someone
vouches for Jon Snow that she trusts
like Sir Jorah it looks like after that
moment that they shared together did she
trust him more than anyone else even
though that wasn't always the case it
just seems like she loves him so if he
were to tell her something
she would be more likely to believe it
the Lords of the north like the little
bear are even more stubborn you're going
to have to give them some concrete proof
so Samwell with all his books Scrolls
evidence from the Citadel is capable of
doing that so even though Sir Jorah
might not be azor Ahai himself he's
still a very critical piece of that
puzzle sir Jorah instrument of prophecy
critical to the coming together of these
two big forces you can see how you know
with this convergence of narrative in
the economy of narrative how they're
taking really big characters that you
care about really big callbacks to
moments in previous seasons and
conveying really important plot points
through them the really important parts
of this are in learning Jon Snow's true
heritage finding evidence of that Jorah
curing his greyscale in Samwell learning
about the importance of dragonglass you
remember the offhanded way that the show
started teasing that Rhaegar Targaryen
might not be the person that everyone
made him out to be that Robert made him
out to be at the beginning of the series
she should be on a hill and where were
the sun's and the clouds above she was
my sister this is where she belongs
she belongs with me in my dreams
I'd kill another night it's done you
grace Targaryen czar gone not all of
them saw her once it's a boy you to meet
your mother's family Lord whent
of the great tourney at Harrenhal when
Rhaegar won everyone cheered for their
prince until he rode right past his wife
Elia Martell and all the smiles died and
he lay a crown of winter roses in
lyanna's lap how many tens of thousands
had to die because Rhaegar chose your
aunt yes he chose her and then she
kidnapped and raped
you hear Robert's comment everything
that you see tells you that he is the
hero of the story but then you get this
really big bomb drop in an offhanded
remark maybe the things that you
believed weren't true this is where the
big twist was a Zora hi comes in so the
idea that it's not any one person even
Rhaegar himself as we learn from
Littlefinger was not a bad guy from
Barristan Selmy who told really funny
stories about him he took the strict
letter of the prophecy that it would be
a child of his a prince who was promised
but it's a Valyrian prophecy in high
Valyrian is gender-neutral so the big
twist I think then is that it's going to
be two people Daenerys and Jon Snow not
just one Ozora high figure so let me
know how do you think that sir Jorah is
going to figure into the revelation of
all this important information in season
7 you know say congratulations to the
new giveaway winner Eddie Lindsay please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there was a new round that
started in this video on outs the winner
the next time I post a Game of Thrones
video please leave all your requests for
bonus videos in the comments below
because it's Superbowl weekend I'll be
posting a bunch of trailers later
tonight so there'll be links coming out
through the rest of the day while you
wait for that you can click here for
more Game of Thrones Season 7 videos and
you can click here for more Super Bowl
trailers thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
the next video
you